at the end of the day it is about love
if it's not we're in trouble I mean we
can say that interpersonally we could
say that as a species we could say it as
a
planet well I've had a lot of scenarios
where I just barked before I even
thought the reason I love your
reputation so much is because I want to
live my life by that is to be a good
person like at my job with my kids but
there's a problem I have with rebellion
and Authority Rebellion good it is it is
of course Rebellion is usually a
thoughtful gesture it just it depends on
what you do with your bite not a fighter
I'm a lover I don't no no because if
you're a lover you got to be a fighter
because if you don't fight for your love
what kind of love do you have no I'm
Kidd